- Welcome everyone to the
Refugee Migration Workshop.
I'm Steven Wilkinson, I'm the director
of the MacMillan Center within
which the program is located.
It gives me my very great pleasure today
to welcome my friend and colleague,
Professor Nicholas Sambanis,
to present on his work on
overcoming discrimination.
Professor Sambanis is a leading authority
in international relations.
He's written really
foundational works on civil war
and peace and conflict
and intervening to preserve peace.
And more recently,
his interests have also
moved towards looking at
domestic politics and
overcoming discrimination
around the world, and
especially in Europe.
And that's what he's gonna
be speaking on today.
And he's recently published this book,
"Native Bias: Overcoming
Discrimination against Immigrants"
which as we know is timely,
really everywhere in the world.
So we welcome also the people
who are watching online.
You can submit questions in the chat
and have a chance to
have Professor Sambanis
answer those in the Q and A.
So, welcome Professor Sambanis.
- Thank you, thank you very
much for this invitation.
I was asked to present this book
that I was coauthored with Danny Choi
and Mathias Poertner,
who are postdoctoral fellows at my lab,
the Identity & Conflict Lab at Penn
and now assistant professors
at Brown and LLC respectively.
And the topic of the conversation today
and of the book is on strategies
to reduce native bias against immigrants,
Muslim immigrants, in
particular in Europe.
And the title of the
presentation, as you can see,
is, Can Shared Norms of Good Citizenship
Reduce Native-Immigrant Conflict?
And we're motivated to study this topic
by the observations that
are being made constantly
around Europe, that natives are actually
opposed to immigration.
You see in your screen here,
data from several countries in
Europe with people responding
to the question that there are
so many immigrants living here
that it doesn't feel like home anymore.
And you see that in Italy,
France, and Germany, for example.
About half of the population
agrees with that statement.
In Greece, where I'm from, 85%
of the population in a
survey that was done,
I believe in 2020, would
agree with the statement
that the number of immigrants is too large
and the percentage agreeing
among the young people,
age 17 to 34, who are usually
more liberal, more accepting
than older people, is 70%, which is huge.
And 56% of the population believe
that immigrants are actually negative,
have a negative impact on
the economy, which is strange
because there are entire
sectors of the Greek economy
that just do not operate
without migrant labor like
agriculture, tourism, and
construction for example.
And 84% prefer all refugees who arrived
at the 2015 refugee
crisis to leave Greece.
These are pretty staggering
numbers suggesting
hostility towards immigrants.
And one of the objectives of this book
and of the broader project that
I'll talk to you about today
is to uncover the causes of immigrant bias
and then to consider potential
strategies to reduce that, right?
So there is a very large
literature in political science
on this topic, particularly
on causes of native bias
and causes of prejudice in
general towards all kinds
of minority groups, not just immigrants.
And I've organized them here in a list of,
so the three dominant explanations are,
one, that it might be racist
and just xenophobia prejudice
towards any group that is not part
of the ingroup and is
culturally or different
in respect to any kind of characteristics.
And there is some evidence
of this both with respect
to immigrant groups, but
also other minority groups.
A second very popular explanation is
that economic competition between natives
and immigrants is what explains
hostility towards immigrants.
You know, this is a
very popular explanation
in the United States and also in Europe.
But interestingly, there
is very little evidence
to support this, you know,
from cross-country studies.
So the least likely
explanation is that one,
as far as the literature
is concerned at the moment.
And then the third
and the most likely explanation for
what causes bias against immigrants is
that cultural differences
between the native population
and the immigrant groups create
the perception of threat.
And that is what motivates natives
to react against immigration
because they perceive immigrants
as potentially changing the
national identity, right?
So they see the symbols
of cultural difference of
immigrants in this picture here,
it's the hijab that these
women are wearing as a symbol
of change that is unwelcome
in native society.
The theory that we develop in the book
is grounded in social
psychological theories
of intergroup conflict
that are not specific
to native immigrant relations,
but we extend those to some extent
and we apply insights
from these literatures.
And what I have here in
bold is the statement
that conflict over waves
of life is at the heart
of opposition to
multiculturalism in Europe.
That's I think the theoretical perspective
that has received the most
support in survey based
and experimental research
in political science in Europe.
And the reason is that natives are priors
and stereotypes about the
extent to which immigrants live
by different rules and different norms,
and also the extent
to which these norms are just
different from their own.
And that generates social distance
between natives and indigenous, right?
So the larger that social
distance, the larger the bias.
And that's an insight that
comes out of the literature
and social psychology
that I mentioned earlier.
And "Native Bias", the book
that I'm presenting today
tests the power of shared norms and ideas
to reduce expressions of
native immigrant hostility
by reducing the perception
of social distance
separating these groups.
And in an ongoing, the
book is out already,
so I'll present the empirical
results from the book,
but I also at the end
discuss some extensions
that I have ongoing currently, right?
So I mentioned that the theory,
the theoretical foundation
of the book lies in social
psychology literature
that goes back decades in
particular social identity theory
and which has taught us
that any kind of descriptive
or other group based
difference can generate bias
even if those differences
are not felt deeply
and they don't have baggage.
So we can create artificial
groups in the lab
and assign people to these
groups, and that will generate
hostility and competition
between the two groups.
And a lot of that literature
has then gone on to try
to figure out ways to reduce bias
and reduce conflict between groups
and expression versions of those arguments
have found their way in political science.
And there are some arguments
out there about ways
to reduce conflict between
natives and immigrants
that require immigrants
to assimilate completely
to native society by shedding the markers
of the difference, right?
So assimilating by
adapting names that are not
visibly foreign, for example,
or are changing the religion.
So these forms of coercive assimilation
are juxtaposed to the types of strategies
that we're considering in this book,
which are far less coercive
and which consist of
converging on a set of norms
of good citizenship
that if applied, if used
and implemented in everyday
settings, both by natives
and immigrants, can generate
the perception that everyone
is part of a common
ingroup as citizen ingroup.
And by doing so, that
should reduce the import
of descriptive markers
and cultural differences
that can persist, right?
So in other words,
if immigrants behave in
ways that natives perceived
as not threatening vis-a-vis norms
and values that they share,
then they should no longer
care about any visible markers
of difference, racial, ethnic, religious,
or other markers that
immigrants might have.
And therefore there should be
less pressure for immigrants
to assimilate by shedding those markers.
That's an idea here.
And by the way, you can
jump in with questions
anytime you'd like in the presentation.
So the data for this book
comes from experiments
that we run in Germany
between 2018 and 2019
and for the field experiments
and expanded later with
some survey experiments
in 2020 and 2021.
We chose Germany because
it was one of two countries
that were most affected by
the refugee crisis of 2015.
The other one being Greece
and Germany received
more than one and a half
million applications for asylum
after the Syrian refugee crisis.
And over a long period,
even prior to 2015,
there was growing opposition
to multiculturalism.
But it's not the most
anti-immigrant nation in Europe,
Italy and Hungary probably
hold that distinction right now, at least.
Germany is about in the middle.
Like if you look at indices of opposition
to multiculturalism in Europe,
Germany is is roughly
in the middle, right?
So it's a large country that's important
and has a very large
population of migrants
going back generations
since the post-war period
when they had the worker program.
And so it has had a lot of experience
with foreign populations
and it was hit really hard
in this recent crisis.
Therefore, it's a good case study.
And what we did to generate
data for this project is
that we created what we call
microenvironments of social interactions
designed to observe the
degree of assistance
that is offered to strangers
in everyday interactions, right?
So we focus on everyday settings
in which people interact
with each other
because we feel that
this gives us a glimpse
into the types of information
that people receive about others,
information about the extent
to which one is accepted
or excluded in society, right?
So the idea is that
if you observe a stranger
offering you help
in one instance, and this
happens many, many times
over time, that will shape
your perceptions of the degree
to which you're accepted as
an equal in that society.
So these everyday settings
that were analyzed
in this project are
interactions in train stations,
actually platforms when
people wait the train
to go to work or travel.
Germany has many large cities
with many large stations
and there are stations with
like 20, 30, 21 or 24 platforms.
So, and people just gather there
and there's a constant
stream of new people who sit
for a while and then leave.
And that gives us access
to a lot of bystanders
whose behavior we can
observe in real time,
in a real setting after
exposing them to an experiment
and intervention that they do not know
is artificial and is set up by us.
So I'm gonna present two
experiments of this sort here,
plus a bunch of survey
experiments that we did
to tease apart specific mechanisms
that can explain the results
from a field experiments.
The first one consists
of a stage violation
of the norm against literary,
which Germans care a lot about.
Actually, another reason
why Germany is a good case
for this analysis is
because they care a
lot about rules, right?
So rule following is a norm
in its own right no matter
what kind of work.
So if you ride the bike at night
in Germany without a light,
people will scream at you, everyone.
If you cross the street,
people will yell at you from
both sides of the street.
If you have a child while
you scream across the street,
they can scream even more, you know, so
it's a good test case.
And at the end of the talk,
I'm gonna compare it a
little bit to Greece,
which is precisely the opposite.
People in general don't follow norms.
They don't really care if you follow norms
and no one is gonna intervene to make sure
that you follow the norm.
So we have a multi-country study
that we were developing now
with (indistinct) who
is post-doc associate
with my lab, in an economist based Greece
and Chris (indistinct),
professor at Kings College,
that makes cross country
comparisons of the sort
that I'm gonna talk to you about today.
But today I will only focus on Germany.
So I'm gonna present the setup
of the experiment really briefly.
I'll show you some footage
and I'll show you the results
and then I'll move on to the next one.
So in this experiment we care
about these guys, experimental subjects,
which are basically
ordinary Germans waiting
in train station to get
on a train, basically.
They can be standing, they can be sitting.
And a member of our team,
always male will come in
and violate the norm against
littering by dropping a cup,
paper cup, with coffee,
doesn't have coffee in it,
but he is just finished it.
We'll drop it on the platform.
And then another member of
that team, always a woman
will in some cases
intervene to tell this guy
to pick up his trash basically.
And please place the paper in a trashcan,
thereby signaling to those people here
that she cares about norms
and about cleanliness and
about the country, basically.
Then this team member will take a call.
Someone will call her and
she will have a conversation,
but it's loud enough for
these people here to hear.
And in the next step she will
drop a bunch of possessions
that she's cradling in a paper bag.
The possessions are
groceries, oranges, actually,
the bag is torn at the bottom
and she's instructed
to make a sudden move,
drop her bag, which will
force her to move her arm
and then the oranges
will fall on the floor,
they'll disperse on the ground
and we observe whether these
guys help her pick them up.
That's the setup, right?
I'm gonna go back into the details
and I'll tell you which are
the experimental dimensions
that we manipulate in a little bit.
But first I'll show you the
video of this interaction.
If I can figure out how to start it.
There we go.
This is Daniel Lo,
political science student.
Dropped this cup.
And that's Nestla, she's Turkish.
You see this woman here
already talking about it.
This woman here is working with us
and she's gonna record their reactions.
And this one also, we
have two coders working
with the team, showed him off.
The three women are talking about him.
This guy doesn't care.
Now she's taking her call
and she's talking to a friend
about coming to see her.
Now she's instructed not
to pick up these oranges
for five seconds after she's dropped
so that we can give these
people a chance to pick them up.
So this woman here and the other one
who you saw was standing on that side
have recorded some information.
First of all, they recorded
the number of bystanders
who were sitting, whether
they were sitting or not,
the gender of the bystanders
as subjective estimate of their age.
Are they old or young?
Basically, can they get up
and help or not basically,
and some other things like is anybody
on a wheelchair, cane, all that?
And most importantly,
did anybody help, right?
So our main outcome in the
study is did anyone help
this woman pick up her oranges?
And also how many people help
is a secondary outcome, right?
So that's the intervention
basically, right?
And the key here is that
these people didn't know
that they were part of an experiment.
And we believe that by
generating the situations
and collecting data this
way we get a more organic
and true estimate of
the willingness to help.
Than it would be the case if
we just asked them in a survey,
would you help somebody in need?
In fact, we've done this
and there's a massive difference between
the stated willingness to help people
and the actual help that they provide.
Now what's the experiment
manipulating, right?
So there are three dimensions,
the identity of the confederate,
the language of the phone
call and non-enforcement.
So in the first treatment
dimension we manipulate
the descriptive characteristics
of the female confederate
who does the norm enforcement.
Here you see Stephanie, who's German
and is our native control in this study,
and ML, who is Kurdish.
And she was actually a refugee in Turkey
and became a student.
Now here you'll see that ML is wearing
a hijab in one condition, no hijab,
she's basically dressed the same way
that Stephanie is dressed,
the way most women
of her age dressed in Germany students.
And then here she's wearing
a big cross, you know,
like George Michael level cross, you know,
that's very visible
from far away to signal
that she's Christian, right?
So the idea here is that
social distance between ML
and Stephanie increases as
you go this direction, right?
From right to left.
And our hypothesis drawing
from social identity theory
which says that there is ingroup bias
whenever you highlight group differences
between two groups is that
ML is gonna get much less
help in this condition here
compared to the other two conditions
where she's visibly less
distant from the native control.
But in all cases, we expect her
to receive less help than Stephanie.
The second dimension that we manipulate is
norm enforcement, right?
So I won't go through
this whole thing again,
we'll focus on just on these two things.
So as I mentioned, as
our female punisher will
sometimes enforce the norm,
tell the guy to pick up his trash.
Other times she won't do
anything, she won't care.
Basically she will just sit
there and look at the trash
and then mind her own business.
There's always enforcement
in these experiments, right?
So there's a another team
member who's also a woman
who comes in and tells...
So somebody always tells this
guy to pick up his trash.
And we did that for two reasons.
First, in Germany, somebody's
gonna tell this guy
to pick up his trash anyway.
So we wanted to do it first
before there is intervention
by the bystanders.
And second, there is a
literature in psychology,
I'm not sure how robust the findings are
that there are these spillover effects
by observing positive
behavior, for example.
So if you observe something for social,
somebody doing something nice,
then you might also respond
in a nice way on an entirely
different matter, you know?
So we wanted to keep the observation
of pro-social behavior constant
throughout these experiments.
Because what we really
care about was whether
differences in the identity
of the person making
the experiment, making
the norm enforcement
really drive the results.
So we always had someone
enforcing them on, right? Yes.
- [Attendee 1] Maybe I'm
anticipating a little bit,
but would you run the experiment
also with different gender
for the violator and the punishment?
- Yeah, so that's a
question that we get a lot
and it would be neat to do that.
We didn't do that 'cause
there were 14 conditions
in this experiment.
So then it would've just
blown up logistically.
And that's actually the
reason why in these extensions
that I'm gonna talk about at the end,
we use calibrated adaptations
of these interventions
in a survey based setting that
is much more cost effective
and allows us to check these variations.
We chose women here
because we thought that it was less likely
that there's gonna be trouble, basically,
like if you had a woman littering
and a Muslim immigrant
man telling her off,
that could have been a
dangerous situation in some
of the towns that we went to, for example.
But nobody is gonna be
violent against a woman who's
actually behaving in a pro-social
way and forcing the norm.
It would would be pretty crazy actually.
And it never happened.
So that was the reason why we did this.
But obviously and I think
also helping behavior
tends to be higher baseline for women
than it would be for men.
Some guy drop his oranges,
like pick them up yourself.
So these were the reasons
why we we did that.
Now the third dimension,
which I won't talk much about
in this presentation as part
of the experiment nonetheless
is the language of the phone call, right?
So the woman who was holding the oranges
and either made the intervention
to enforce the norm or
not always took a call.
Actually the guy who was
leaving was the one calling her
and she spoke to him in either in German
or in Arabic or Turkish, okay?
And always had the same same script
that we gave her
basically, which was about,
oh, I'm excited to come see you.
It was something irrelevant basically.
And the whole idea, it was
to make the call sound like
she's talking to her friend
and therefore if she's
talking to a friend in German,
that means that she has German friends
and therefore she's
assimilated to some extent
and her network includes Germans, right?
Which you would expect if it's a native,
but you might not expect if
she's hijab wearing Middle
Eastern woman, right?
And that could also influence behavior.
So that's the experiment.
Now where did we do this?
We did this in train stations
in 31 cities and towns
across three states in former East Germany
and in West Germany here, right?
So there were 34 confederates
across seven teams.
And these blue dots here
are the different cities.
And we were fortunate that
Germany has so many cities
with train stations that we can do this.
I have pilots going on now
in Greece where I'm trying
to do something like this
and it's like impossible basically.
And so we're doing any like
bus stations and metro stations
and every public space you can imagine.
And it's crazy complicated
logistically, right?
So we ran the intervention 1,614 times
and altogether that involved
a little more than 7,000
bystanders and we had 14 treatment
and control conditions when
you combine the manipulations
for the three dimensions of.
This is why we didn't have
male enforces, for example,
or consider other potential
interesting variations of this.
So the main outcome as I mentioned
was did any bystander offer assistance?
And there are logistical
details of the skid basically,
which I won't get into,
but you know, you can't
drop the orange here
and expect somebody from way
down there to run and get it,
although that happened once.
This little girl sprinted
across, you know,
like 20 meters to try to help, you know,
but it had to be within three
meters basically, right?
More or less.
And the oranges had to be on
the ground for a few seconds,
not so long that it becomes weird
that you haven't bent out
to pick them up yourself,
but long enough to give people a chance to
pick them up plus other,
there was like a long protocol
about, you know, what counts
as help, what doesn't.
The results I'm gonna show you here
referred to this binary indicator,
whether any bystander helped or not.
And in this experiment we
only did it in settings
where there were multiple
bystanders, right?
Never just one-on-one.
The next experiment
that I'm gonna show you,
we also did one-on-one interactions.
And that kind of matters actually.
So the hypothesis as I mentioned is that
that just flows straight out
of social psychological
theories of social identity
is that people will
receive less assistance
from bystanders if they're different.
And the more different
they are there was the less
assistance they will receive.
These are the first two.
And the signaling cultural integration
by enforcing value of civic norms
will offset the bias that
we anticipate finding
against Muslim immigrant
enforcers, Muslim immigrants.
These are the main hypothesis.
So I won't talk about
any technical details
in this presentation.
I'll just show some bar graphs basically,
but we can discuss details if you want.
One of the main results is
that there is bias against
immigrants on the basis
of religion in Germany.
The blue column here shows you
that providing help is
fairly common, right?
78% of the cases, there
was some help given
to the confederate
when the confederate was
a German native woman
and it wasn't much different
when it was an immigrant woman
wearing a cross or an immigrant woman
in the control condition
dressed in modern clothes
looking secular basically, right?
So these first three columns here suggest
that phenotypical differences,
just looking like you're
not really German, basically
whatever that means or whatever
people think of German as
doesn't really matter
very much in Germany,
nor does the language actually matter,
which is very interesting
because in other countries in particular
in the United States, other
experiments have shown
that they matter a lot, right?
So there's an interesting experiment done
by Ryan Enos at Harvard
in Boston where he shows
that even just planting some confederates
who are Latinos and
they look visibly Latino
in subway stations, generates
more hostile attitudes
towards affirmative action among
the commuters, for example.
So even seeing someone
who's different racially
and listening to Spanish can
generate hostile responses
in the United States, not in Germany,
would suggest that they're
actually much more okay
with cultural differences
and ethnic difference,
which is what you would expect
when you have such a large
foreign worker population.
Of course you would expect the same thing
in the United States, but it's not.
Now this is interesting here.
If you compare columns three and four,
you see the penalty that women incur
out of just showing that
they believe different things
than the average German
believes by wearing the hijab.
So on average, women,
immigrant women wearing a
hijab get help 66% of the time,
which is pretty good, you
know, more than half the time,
but much less, significantly
less than immigrant,
the same woman not wearing a hijab, right?
Who gets help 76% of the time.
There's a 10% difference.
And that's the amount of the
penalty basically that you get
from being different in
this everyday interaction.
You might say, well, 10% is not a lot.
I don't know if it's a lot,
but it is what we picked up.
And it's also a fairly costless way
of helping someone, right?
Like for someone who is
like not have a bad back
or something, it's nothing to bend down
and pick up an orange again,
especially if the orange hits your leg
or it's really closer to
you than somebody else.
So to withhold that
assistance systematically
towards someone on the basis
of what they look like,
what you think they
believe is a significant
expression of hostility, we think,
and that's how we interpret this.
Now, does norm enforcement
change these results
in some way, right?
So we find that actually
bias, partially offset
by shared norms, but it's not
completely eliminated, right?
So here, starting again
by German enforcer,
we see that they get helped
about 84% of the time,
significantly more than the previous
data that I showed you.
And there is a statistically
significant difference
in the amount of help that
the German native gets
when she enforces a
norm versus not, right?
So she gets more help when
she enforces the norm.
When the immigrant wearing
a hijab enforces the norm,
she also gets much more
help than when she does not.
There is now a 12.5% difference, right?
So the hijab penalty increases when
there is also enforcement
versus non-enforcement.
But an interesting finding
is that the amount of help
that the immigrant woman
wearing a hijab gets
when she enforces the
norm is basically the same
as the amount of help
that the German woman gets when she does
not enforce the norm.
So this is an example of
what you hear frequently being
said in the United States
and other countries,
which is that minorities
and immigrants have to work twice as hard
to get basically the
same kind of treatment
that natives get, right?
So like these women get help the same way,
but this Middle Eastern woman here,
wearing hijab has gone out of her way
to confront this big German
dude, you know, for being rude.
Whereas this woman is
just white, you know,
and they get help the same.
So while we see this increase,
right, from 60% to 73%
and it's statistically significant,
and therefore we know
that pro-social behavior
by immigrants is recognized,
there's still a difference
in difference basically.
And immigrant women, I'm sorry,
native women still get help more, right?
This is not trivial though, right?
Because it could have been the case
that non-enforcement was
completely discounted
when done by an immigrant, right?
And we didn't find it.
So it could have been the case
that these columns were equal, right?
So maybe people didn't,
and the fact that they're not suggests
that Germans actually
value non-enforcement
and rules more than the antipathy
that many of them feel
towards other people.
Or it suggests that
the reason that they have
this antipathy might be
that they make assumptions
about the things
that immigrants actually believe, right?
So when you resolve that uncertainty
and you show them that they
actually share the same ideas
to some extent that the negative attitude
to immigrants isn't used.
So that's the main result.
- [Attendee 2] Can I ask you something?
- [Nicholas] Yes.
- [Attendee 2] Now the third person,
when she tells the guy
to pick up his trash,
I assume she has to speak German?
- In German with a slight accent.
Slight accent, yes.
So now you might wonder, why?
So what drives this?
What is the mechanism, basically?
What do people think about when
they see an immigrant woman
either reacting prosocially
by telling the guy
to pick up his trash
or not caring basically
when she stands right next
to somebody who litters.
So to figure that out,
'cause we didn't have data on this
from our field experiment.
We ran a survey experiment in
maybe a few months
later, I believe in 2020,
where we showed videos from these
interventions and
pictures of litter streets
and collected data on basically
beliefs about littering,
about why Germans litter,
why immigrants litter
who litters more and so on.
And we found out that the
majority of Germans think
that immigrants litter more than Germans.
And when you ask them why
in an open-ended response
and you do a little word
cloud of their responses,
you see that this word
homeland and respect
and habit is what comes up more frequently
in spontaneous responses about, you know,
why immigrants litter,
they litter because they're not from here,
this isn't their homeland,
they don't really care,
they don't have the habit
not to litter, right?
Which suggest that it's all about respect
and showing respect and affinity
for the new country, right?
And that is what registers,
when they observe an immigrant
woman enforcing the norm,
that she actually does care
and she respects the country
that she lives in now
and therefore she can be considered part
of the citizen ingroup.
But on the basis of this
experiment that is not enough
to eliminate all bias, right?
Because there's still a
difference in difference
in the results I showed you.
So far we've learned
that Germans discriminate
against Muslims in everyday
interactions to some extent
that ethnolinguistic differences
and phenotypical differences
don't really matter.
And therefore, this discrimination
must be driven by what people read
into these descriptive differences, right?
What do they think the
hijab means, for example.
And that these perceptions
of normative differences
with immigrants, that underlie the bias
can be manipulated and
when you change them,
that can reduce the bias
but not eliminate it.
So what are the mechanisms
underlying this again, right?
So social psychological
theory in particular
common ingroup identity model,
which was developed
by Gartner and Dovidio,
who is here at Yale
suggests some possible
explanations and mechanisms.
Two mechanisms that they have suggested
is rec-categorization and
de-categorization, right?
So the idea is that you
can reduce prejudice
or someone else if you can
redefine that person as a member
of a common ingroup, right?
Rather than a member
of a hostile outgroup.
What can this common ingroup
be when we're dealing
with natives and immigrants?
It can't be a national ingroup,
but it could be a citizen ingroup, right?
So the idea that we had here is
that if everyone behaves the same way
and they show that they
share the same ideas about
standards of appropriate civic
behavior, they can be part
of a shared citizen ingroup.
And that is the way that
they can be recategorized
as an ingroup member
from an outgroup member
or a different mechanism, is
that they can decategorized
as a member of a hostile outgroup
by considering these people
as not typical members of
that hostile outgroup, right?
So you could look at the
person, the immigrant woman
with a hijab who's enforcing the norm
and think of her as a good
citizen, not as a Muslim.
Or you can look at her and
say, yeah, yes, she's a Muslim,
but she's a good Muslim,
not a bad Muslim like the
others, basically, right?
So the first would be recategorization,
the second would be
decategorization mechanism.
So, and we wanted to
test these mechanisms.
And a third thing that we wanted to test
is whether the benefit
of prosocial behavior
that is generated by
observing norm enforcement
by one person generalizes to the group,
or is it restricted to
the person itself, right?
So to do that we ran
another survey experiment
which consisted of showing
people videos, right?
Now, this video here
was filmed by us and it was
as if randomly captured
on the phone, right?
So Mattias was sitting here on a bench
and he was taking a video with his phone
of the surroundings in the back, right?
And he was saying, oh look,
they finished the construction
at the station, you know the
way people do all the time
and then they post the stuff
on YouTube or TikTok, right?
And then as he was doing that,
these people walk into the frame, right?
And then we repeated this intervention,
not the norm enforcement,
just the littering, I'm
sorry, not the oranges part,
just a norm violation and
the enforcement, right?
So this guy who's pretty huge actually,
and he wouldn't want to
tell him off, you know,
without police around you
or something, drops his cup.
And then this woman who's
pretty small actually tells him
to pick up his trash or not, you know?
So in one iteration she just sits there
and they're actually, her friends are
sitting just off that frame.
There were some versions
in which there were a
group of four and other
versions in which she was alone.
So we have an experiment again in which
norm violation is either sanctioned
or not sanctioned by a woman who is either
a Muslim woman wearing a hijab
or a German woman, right?
So we have videos of all of
these different conditions
and we upload them on
YouTube in an account
and channel that we created,
we let them sit there for a while
and then we use the link in
a survey instrument saying,
look, we wanna know
what you think about these
situations which we found online,
including this video that
we happen to find online.
So it's as if it's a real intervention
that we capture in the field.
And we implement the survey
in a sample of 2500 German
adults in November, 2020.
And we are interested in
measuring responses using
this item basically.
So after they view the video,
they're asked to consider
whether the person in the video is similar
and how similar that person is
to an outstanding German citizen, right?
Are they 0% similar, 20% similar, 40%,
and so on until identical
basically, right?
This is a common way of measuring
perceived similarity in
the American politics,
literature and economics.
And we call this the
recategorization item.
Because the idea is that
if the person in question
is an immigrant wearing a hijab
and you think that she's
a hundred percent similar
to a good outstanding citizen,
then you're thinking
about her as a citizen
rather than as a foreigner, right?
Because an upstanding German
citizen would've done exactly
what a person did
in the iterations where they
enforced the norm, right?
So I won't show you all the analysis,
I'll just give you a
snapshot of the results.
And the results are that
norm enforces are seen
as more similar to good Germans citizens,
regardless of whether they
were a hijab or no hijab.
The hijab no longer
matters basically, right?
So we have a very large shift
from zero to a hundred, although
it's not a hundred, okay?
And norm enforcers,
so we have evidence of the
recategorization mechanism
and norm enforcers are
seen as not typical members
of the group, right?
When the normal enforcer
is an immigrant, right?
So a Muslim woman enforcing the norm
is seen as more similar
to a good German citizen
and because she's not a
typical Muslim, right?
So these are the main results here
and the benefit of norm enforcement,
seeing this norm enforcement
in the video doesn't change
your views of Muslims as
a group in general, right?
So yes, you recognize that this one person
did something good.
Yes, it's closer to a good German citizen,
(indistinct) as a whole
are still as bad or as good
as we thought about previously, right?
So there is evidence of
both recategorization
and decategorization, and
this one shot intervention
that we did in the video
doesn't really change
perceptions of the group in general.
That might also be true, is probably true
in the field as well.
So seeing somebody doing
something good in the field
who's from a different
outgroup is probably not
gonna change your worldview
about everybody else.
But our hypothesis is that
if you were to see examples
of such pro-social behavior
over and over again
by many different people everywhere,
that should over time change your views.
But that's still untested.
So now you might ask,
"Well what about other norms?"
Okay, so we talked about littering,
but littering is kind of a generic,
not littering is a generic exhibit norm.
Everybody kind of feels
the same way about it.
It's hard to find someone who's
gonna tell you in a survey,
yes, I'd like to litter, you know,
but maybe the reason that we find
that the diff in diff still there is
because enforcing a non littering norm
has shallow effects, right?
You'll give somebody the benefit
of saying that you feel a
little closer to that person
because they enforce the norm,
but it's not gonna change
the way you feel about
that person massively.
What about if we focus
on group specific norms?
And by that we mean civic
norms that affect your subgroup
of the population more, right?
To do these generate stronger effects.
And here we focus on
gender equity and norms
about gender roles in particular.
We hypothesize
that the reason that women
wearing a hijab in Germany
get penalized and discriminated against
in this public settings is
because people make assumptions
about their beliefs
regarding gender equality.
'Cause they see a hijab,
they assume that the woman
is regressive vis-a-vis
gender equality norms.
And they punish her for that
by not helping her when she needs help.
What if we actually
were able to communicate
that woman's beliefs about
gender roles in the same way
that we did in the previous experiment?
Would that change things in the field?
So we designed and another experiment
that tested exactly that, right?
So our hypothesis is that
discrimination against Muslims
is likely driven by beliefs
that they have regressive
ideas about gender.
That is a big topic
actually in immigration,
studies of immigration in Europe,
gender and the role of women
in Muslim societies versus
Christian societies is a point
of conflict and debate.
So we confirm actually
that this assumption is
widely shared in Germany
in a standard survey.
So we tell them,
"What do you think about
hijab", for example?
And repression is what
comes immediately as
the most commonly mentioned
word in this survey.
So we said, "Well what
if Muslim women signal
that they actually have
progressive ideas about German?"
Does that reduce discrimination
and does that make the
hijab just an irrelevant
cultural symbol that they
wear for other reasons, right?
Rather than to signal political ideology
that is contrary to the
dominant view in Germany.
And we did that with
another field experiment
the following summer, summer of 2019,
which had the same idea,
but we dropped lemons this time.
So rather than oranges, right?
So here is Nestle,
she is the same woman that you saw before.
She loved being part of this whole thing.
So she re-upped this the
second she lived in Cologne
and she was a political
science student, she's Turkish.
So she approaches a group of people
who could be standing
or talking or sitting
and she takes a call, right?
And in the call she
will reveal her beliefs
about gender equality.
And I'll tell you how.
So we manipulate two dimensions here.
The first is the identity
of the confederate.
Just like in the previous one,
she can be a German native.
This is Charlotte.
She was in one of these German teams
and this is Raneem who's a Syrian refugee.
And here is Raneem in
the control condition
wearing no hijab.
And here is Raneem wearing
hijab basically, right?
So we have three
conditions, immigrant hijab,
immigrant no hijab and native.
And these women dressed,
depending on the way that the condition
that they were assigned to
suggest they should be dressed,
would approach this group
and have a conversation in which
they reveal their views
on gender by saying
one of these three things.
So in one condition she will speak,
she's always speaking to a friend of hers
and she's expressing her
emotional state about a
decision that her sister took
to either take a job or not, right?
So in their regressive condition message,
she says, "Hi, thanks for calling back.
I'm really mad. My sister's
a terrible mother."
There's a word for that in German
that people really pay attention to
when they listen to it, like raven mother.
Although I don't know if
ravens are bad mothers or not.
She prefers to work instead of looking
after her children and
her husband at home.
And then there's a pause
and then she says, "I think
that as a woman she stay at home
and look after her family.
I've never been so mad
since we moved to Germany."
We added this sentence to make clear
that these people were actually immigrants
or recent immigrants
because that wasn't actually
clear in the first experiment.
And then in the progressive
message, it's the same setting.
The sister takes a job or not,
but she's happy about that, right?
So a woman, "I'm really happy,
very proud of my sister,
she decided to go to work.
She shouldn't just stay at home to look
after her children and husband, right?"
And the control condition,
she basically has similar
length conversation
with a friend about
some irrelevant subject.
Oh, I'm coming to see you, I'm excited,
blah, blah, blah, right?
- [Attendee 1] And what
does the control person say
then regarding Germany?
- She says, I'm happy to come to see you.
And then something happened in her life.
I can't remember what we said now.
And then it ends with
basically the same thing.
I'm happy, so she's happy in the control,
happy in the progressive
and mad in the regressive.
Now the data collection
here lasted five weeks,
25 cities, in 26 train
stations in NRW, Saxony,
and Lower Saxony.
And here we repeated this
situation 1,830 times
and we had almost 4,000 bystanders, right?
Again, within three meters.
In a pilot the spring before,
Mathias and I went to Frankfurt
and we ran this like about 250 times
and we then had a team of people come
and interview everybody who was around.
So we established that
in like 98% of the times
they noticed the confederate.
96% of the time they noticed the call.
And 86% of the times they
could tell you exactly
what she said, even when
they were wearing headphones,
which is pretty weird I think.
But it is what it is.
You know, so very nosy people
who wanna know what's going on
around them, which works for
this experiment quite well.
So here we collect data on
how many bystanders there were
and we collect, in this
instance we were better at it.
So we had individual level data.
We had up to seven bystanders.
And then for each bystander,
what's the gender of that person?
Were they wearing headphones?
What is the subjective
estimate of the age bracket
or the potential of immigrant background?
That's all subjective obviously.
And did this bystander offer assistance?
And that allows us to analyze
the data both by iteration,
did anybody help in that iteration or not?
But also to say something about
or women help more or not.
And that was useful because
after the intervention,
we had a survey,
another team came in a few minutes later
and said, "Oh, we're from
this university in this town,
we're running the survey, doing the study.
Can we do a survey about
social issues in Germany?"
It was extremely hard
to get people to say yes
to that unfortunately.
And we didn't really get great data.
We tried everything,
tried giving away $2,000.
We tried this weird system
where we gave them these cards
and we could track them so they
can actually take the survey
later when they wanted to
and they never worked well basically.
But we have some data
that we can actually match
with the individual level data
and that gives us some
interesting findings actually.
So the first result is that
we replicate the finding
from the previous summer,
which is that there is bias
on the basis for religion, right?
We have the average level of
help is about the same, 76%.
It was 78% in 2018 for the native.
And it's basically the same
for the immigrant control,
no discrimination there, but it's 67.5%
for the immigrant with a hijab.
And that difference is
statistically significant.
Exactly the same as before.
And here's the interesting stuff here.
So lots of dimensions here to consider.
The first dimension is just
compare the bluish columns
with the reddish columns.
And we see that the bluish columns,
which are all about natives,
the different conditions,
progressive, neutral or
aggressive in the natives
are all about the same.
Whereas there are
differences in immigrants.
So basically what these native women say
doesn't really influence
whether they get help or not.
So whereas for immigrants,
it matters quite a bit whether
they appear to be progressive
or regressive, right?
And the progressive woman wearing a hijab
gets helped just as much.
There's no statistically
significant difference
as the German woman in
any condition, right?
So there's no longer any bias
towards Muslim women when
they appear to be regressive.
And that result is driven
by women, German women.
German women no longer
discriminate against Muslim women
when the Muslim woman
appears to be progressive.
There is a significant penalty
to wearing hijab when it
is associated in confirming
the priors that this woman
is regressive, right?
But there is no analogous penalty
to being regressive if
you're German, right?
So that in and of itself
can be interpreted
as a subtle sign of bias, right?
So basically white
German women are allowed
to have whatever views they
have and you'll still help them.
But the Muslim women, that's
not the case basically, right?
So you help them only if they show you
that they believe the same
thing that you believe.
Now men are not affected at all
by this intervention, right?
It doesn't change their reaction.
In fact, they discriminate
a little more against women
in the progressive condition
and the regressive condition
relative to the control.
Like whenever they talk basically
it upsets them a little bit
(audience laughing)
and they help them a little less,
but it's only a very, very
small annoyance penalty.
So, but they don't care
basically if the Muslim women are
regressive or so there's
something else that's driving male
discrimination against Muslim women.
And the third finding,
which comes from the
individual level data,
is that this entire set of
results comes from secular.
There's a 50 percentage points
difference in the help rate
among women who declare to be religious
and women who declare to be atheist.
And the secular women
in Germany are the ones
who appreciate the progressive message.
Christian women do not
in fact sometimes punish
the German women for that position, right?
Just as in the previous
example, we follow up
with a survey experiment to
figure out exactly why do people
discriminate against
the hijab wearing women.
And we ran a survey
showing them a video of one
of our confederates when she wears a hijab
who drops her oranges in front
of these German people
and nobody helps her.
And we ask them,
"Why do you think she
doesn't get any help?"
And the most common
explanation, like at 65%
of the people give you
immediately is that it's
because they think that she does not think
that women are equal
and they think women should
be subordinate, right?
So the whole idea here is that
when people look at the
hijab as a symbol of Islam,
they assume that it's a
symbol of political Islam
and that it means that it represents
a set of politically
regressive beliefs, which can,
if you allow a lot of Muslims to come in
and live in Germany, shape
the politics of the country
and causing backtracking on
advances in women's rights
that have occurred over time, right?
So that's what as the explanation
that we believe drives
the results that we find.
And men are not responsive to this
because they don't really care
that much about the progress
that is made in women race
because they don't
really benefit from this.
Just to close basically
because I told you, I'll
tell you where this is going.
So we're interested in these questions.
You know, does race play a role?
What if the enforcer is male?
What if we're talking about
other norms, you know,
not just littering and gender equity.
It's extremely complicated
to do this in the field.
And these experiments
are massively complicated logistically.
So we were in the field from
like seven in the morning
until seven, eight at night every day
for five, six weeks at a time.
And we have 55 people working
across the country basically for months.
So it's not possible to look at these
in a field experiment setting.
So what we're doing now is we're creating
calibrated versions of these interventions
in survey experiments.
And I can tell you a little
more about how that is done.
And the idea is to run survey experiments
in all European union countries
with very large samples
of about 4,000 people per country.
But we measure first try to find out
what norms do you these
European citizens care about
among a larger set of norms
that define good citizenship,
rank order these norms
and create norm hierarchies
for every country.
And then see whether people
apply these hierarchies
consistently to evaluate natives
and immigrants in every country.
And that involves basically
a two stage process
where we elicit beliefs
about the norms that matter,
and perceptions about what
other people in this countries
think is the right way of behaving, right?
And that will tell us whether
there's an implicit consensus
in the European Union, perhaps
as a result of being part
of the union about what it
means to be a good citizen
and whether those norms of
good citizenship are applied
to judge natives and immigrants equally.
So just to wrap up,
we learned in this book
that there are cultural
differences cause bias
that coercive assimilation,
you know, changing your name
or dropping the hijab
might not be necessary
if you can disconnect
what these symbols
actually mean politically
from the religious or other
cultural significance.
But we also learned that norm enforcement
and adhering to valued norms
might actually not be enough
to eliminate all bias.
And that multiculturalism has some limits.
So you can overcome
descriptive differences,
but natives will resist abandoning norms
and ideas that define their identities
that they've developed over time
and they've been socialized
in for the benefit of
accommodating newcomers and
the values that they represent.
So there are some policy
implications of this research
as well that we're trying to uncover
now in the work that is ongoing.
And one result is that
there is no easy way of
creating like some public
information campaign
that will work for everybody
and reduce bias, you know, so,
and that's unfortunate,
but the multidimensionality of
social identities basically,
and the complicated way in
which the different identities
intersect, make it impossible for us
to have a single measures that
will work well for everyone.
And we saw that in the
gender experiment where
the message that these women
are actually progressive works
very well on women, some
women, secular women,
but not at all among Christian women
and men are indifferent basically, right?
So imagine if you had a
public information campaign
basically that highlighted some feature
of an immigrant population.
It could work for a subset of population
but not for the entire population.
So it's very hard
to find a scalable public
information campaign
that can just eliminate prejudices
and misperceptions just like that.
And as a first step for a policy design
that actually address
these issues, we think that
we need to collect more
information about first,
what are the priors that people have
about different immigrant groups?
How do they expect them to behave?
Which norms do they
think they will violate
and which they will adhere to?
And then how much do people
care about the specific norms
that immigrants are likely to violate?
And once we have that information,
we can then create citizenship classes
that can inform not just immigrants,
but also natives about this.
They can share the information
with both native populations
and immigrant populations leading to
fewer misperceptions about the degree
to which immigrants are non violators
and pushing both groups
towards a convergence
in their public behaviors
and adherence to the set of
norms of good citizenship
that could allow this
recategorization mechanism
that we described to take call basically.
So I'll stop here.
(audience clapping)
- [Attendee 1] There is a
question on line if you for now.
If you join me thanking
Professor Sambanis for this...